قالت نقابه الصحفيين السودانيه ان قوه
مسلحه تابعه للدعم السريع اقتحمت شقت
الصحفي في مكتب قناه الجزيره في الخرطوم
وعضو نقابه الصحفيين السودانيين الزميل
احمد الصديدي في منطقه الخرطوم بحري واضاف
ان الزميل احمد فضل والمصور المتعاون في
مكتب قناه الجزيره راشد جبريل تعرضا للضرب
مع رفاقهما وقام افراد الدعم السريع بنهب
هواتفهم النقاله وغيرها من الممتلكات
كذلك دانه نقابه تعرض الصحفيه عيسى دفع
الله للاعتداء بالضرب ونهب هاتفه وامواله
من مجموعه تابعه للدعم السريع وذلك خلال
تغطيته الاحداث في نيالا واشارت الى
استهداف منزل مراسل للاذاعه السودانيه
خالد شرف الدين في جنوب دارفور وذلك ضمن
سلسله احداث العنف التي تشهدها الولايه
كما رفضت النقابه استهداف الصحفيين
وترويعهم واشارت الى انها تحمل اطراف
النزاع المسلح المسؤوليه الكامله عن
سلامتهم وهم يعملون في ظروف بالغه التعقيد